[Música]
todos
si pudieran calcular el porcentaje de
felicidad de su existencia ésta podría
ser una opción tomando los momentos
felices buenos tranquilos y los maman
los momentos malos tristes y adversos
que resultado les daría
la onu en su índice anual de felicidad
estableció que colombia este año ocupa
el puesto número 43 dentro del ranking
mundial de felicidad
encuentro que para establecer estas
cifras se tienen en cuenta criterios
como el producto interno bruto como la
esperanza de vida y la corrupción entre
otros
entonces me puse a pensar si esas cifras
representan mi felicidad
hasta mis 6 años de vida crecí con mi
padre mi madre y mis tres hermanos en
medio de una linda familia
rodeada de un ambiente bonito en un
prestigioso sector al norte de bogotá
un 21 de diciembre fallece mi padre y
repentinamente el 22 de diciembre nos
encontrábamos durmiendo en una plaza
pública del parque nacional en el frío
pavimento con mi padre mi madre y mis
tres hermanos
allí hubo un cambio dramático de vida y
a partir de este momento cambiaría todo
empezando porque nos ponemos a vivir al
otro extremo de la ciudad muy al sur
en donde crecí hasta mis 16 años en un
ambiente hostil rodeada de maltratos
abusos drogas alcohol un escenario muy
difícil para crecer
en esta etapa enterramos a uno de mis
hermanos muy joven y a los otros dos los
vi cavar su propia tumba para enterrarse
en vida
tengo muchos recuerdos de esta época de
mi crecimiento porque marcaron
profundamente mi conciencia como por
ejemplo el significado de las navidades
a partir de la muerte de mi padre hasta
que el vídeo era la época más esperada
del año tengo recuerdos muy felices
armando todos el armónico de la navidad
destapando los regalos junto a mis
hermanitos viendo a mis padres celebrar
bailar brindar la casa llena de
invitados que acudían allí a celebrar
las fiestas porque era un muy buen lugar
para hacerlo
a partir de este 21 de diciembre serían
las navidades más tristes de muchos de
los años de nuestra vida especialmente
para mi hermanito menor y para mí
porque en el nuevo entorno había mucho
consumo de alcohol y como ya les decía
de drogas y con esto venían los abusos
los maltratos venía el miedo en esta
época
o como por ejemplo cuando teniendo 12
años fue invitada a presentar un casting
para unas fotos y cuando llegue al lugar
intentaron convencerme a hacerlas
desnuda bajo el aprendizaje pagarme muy
bien porque a su vez unos adultos
pagarían muy bien por estas fotos o
cuando teniendo 14 años lo invitaron a
hacer un desfile de pijamas para un
catálogo y me di cuenta cuando llegué al
lugar del evento que había sido engañada
porque las prendas ya no eran pijamas
era ropa interior que además debería
utilizar húmeda en un lugar privado para
un grupo de senadores y políticos de mi
país
en ambos escenarios mi olfato me llevó a
huir de allí y pese a ese buen olfato
que hoy lo reconozco como mi intuición
muy desarrollada en esta misma etapa de
mi vida fue raptada drogada y abusada
por un grupo de hombres durante dos días
así que este episodio me lleva a tomar
una decisión
y es subir de ese entorno no quería
vivir más en la casa de mi madre
entonces me voy con uno de los oficiales
de la policía que reconoció mi caso
abuso
él era el héroe que llega al rescate
como en las películas con uniforme y
todo
entonces me dice madre junto a él a mis
17 años y no mucho tiempo después
decidió abandonar este intento de
familia está idea de hacer un hogar
porque allí los maltratos eran otros
económicos y morales que deberías
aportar porque ningún otro lado iba a
tener las condiciones que allí tenía
porque yo no era nadie
a mis 24 años que era el amor a mi vida
nuevamente
cuatro años después me hago madre de mi
segundo tesoro mi niña menor y ocho
meses después de haber nacido tan solo
ocho meses mi niña cae en un coma
un coma que representaba para ella una
posibilidad de vida de menos del 20 por
ciento y que para la ciencia lo mejor
era que no viviera
el resultado una parálisis cerebral
severa
dos sondas instaladas una para
alimentación y la otra para medicamentos
sondas por las que además nueve meses
después de que mi bebé saliera de la
unidad de cuidados intensivos
yo debería enfrentarme a una junta
médica de diferentes especialidades
entre ellas psiquiatría porque debería
demostrarles con vídeos en mano que no
me estaba imaginando que mi bebé se
alimentaba porque había decidido
siguiendo esa intuición retarme a
regalarle la oportunidad de que volviera
a disfrutar de los alimentos
cuando tengo 33 años a mi hija mayor el
año en el que se graduaba del
bachillerato le diagnosticaron una
enfermedad inmunológica que le daba a
una de cada 10 millones de personas en
el mundo
era una enfermedad tan destructiva que
con el paso del tiempo sería necesario
amputarle sus extremidades
empezando por unos deditos de sus pies
que en ese momento ya se estaban micro
santos
y con toda esta curva de vida y viendo a
mi hija mayor en una clínica el año en
el que justo se grababa del colegio qué
expectativas podría tener yo de pensar
en buscar la felicidad
o encontrar el éxito
se analizaban mi curva de vida resulta
fácil concluir el porcentaje de la
fórmula planteada
muy fácil
y si le sumamos otros factores como
algunas personas del entorno conocidos
compañeros de trabajo amigos familiares
y hasta la pareja diciendo cosas como
usted sí es muy tema las o qué vida tan
infeliz la suya menos posibilidades de
que mi conciencia quisiera conocer la
felicidad o descubrir el éxito
fuerte malas o tener éxito
yo decidí buscar el éxito porque el
haber vivido estas navidades tan
tenebrosas buscando proteger a mi
hermanito le dieron una oportunidad a mi
conciencia de buscar unas navidades
diferentes para de dárselas a mis
generaciones posteriores y esto también
tiene algunas consecuencias distintas mi
familia me soporta cada año tres días y
dos madrugadas amaneciendo armando mi
navidad
y nos preguntan si vendemos artículos
navideños o si estamos compitiendo en
algún concurso
yo escogí buscar el éxito
porque el haberlo perdido todo siendo
apenas una pequeña despertaron en mi
conciencia la diferencia entre el valor
del dinero y lo que valía yo y no me
canje por plata siendo una menor menos
en las estadísticas mundiales de niños
pagados por sexo
yo escogí buscar el éxito
porque el padre de mi hija mayor haya
aparecido en mi vida a mis 16 años
después de un abuso fue una oportunidad
para escapar de aquel entorno y alejarme
de un destino trágico como alguien que
se encontraban muchas de las personas
que me rodeaban
yo escogí buscar el éxito
porque la haberle dado la oportunidad a
mi hija menor de vivir nos devolvió a
nosotros otra oportunidad y espera
sonreír agradecernos y los nueve meses
que llore junto a ella cada día
intentando alimentarla le devolvieron a
ella la oportunidad de volver a
disfrutar de los alimentos y de
retirarse esas tres ondas yo escogí
buscar el éxito
porque cuando mi hija mayor había
enfrentado la morfina y se enfrentaba a
la quimioterapia me pidió que no llorará
y que no sufriera más porque habían
otras opciones
y ella se reto por limitación en su
conciencia a buscar otras oportunidades
para levantarse de esa silla de ruedas
con sus extremidades completas
de malas
de mala si yo no hubiera vivido todo lo
que he vivido para poder hoy estar aquí
frente a todos ustedes y compartirles
una fórmula que diferente a la de la
felicidad es una fórmula de vida que
nunca cambia es una fórmula de vida con
la que enfrentar las dificultades y las
adversidades traerá un impacto diferente
en nuestras generaciones posteriores
de creo
es la capacidad que tenemos de
transformar las dificultades en retos
para que nuestro cerebro active en
nuestra conciencia la facilidad de ver
oportunidades donde parece no haberlas
aplicar el dedo en mi vida me permitió
moverme del lugar en los momentos donde
el pánico el miedo las drogas el abuso
el maltrato la muerte me dejaban
paralizada y si no podía atravesar el
obstáculo pasaba por un lado y cuando me
di cuenta que mi entorno por imitación
aplicaba un modelo de buscar
oportunidades en medio de las
dificultades me di cuenta que podía
llevar a otros escenarios y no solamente
he visto cómo se enfrentan las drogas el
maltrato el abuso buscando opciones he
visto como equipos cuando no cumplen sus
objetivos buscan opciones distintas a
través de las oportunidades a través de
ver en medio de la dificultad de un reto
son solo cuatro pasos
cuatro pasos en identificar reconocer y
afrontar cuatro pasos en donde hago el
inventario de mis recursos veo mis
fortalezas propias y las de mi entorno
cuatro pasos en donde creo mi kit de
acción y ponderó los riesgos y el
impacto que estoy dispuesto a asumir de
estos
y cuatro pasos donde acción y reconozco
las oportunidades que crea este método
está claramente definido en mi libro
pero no tiene ciencia me lleva al final
a ver opciones donde antes no las veía
esta vez mi nieta y hoy ella por
imitación se pone mi ropa
y sus padres aunque quieran evitarle el
profundo dolor de enfrentar dificultades
algún día o adversidades no pueden
garantizarse pero ella por imitación se
activará en su conciencia el modelo
creativo de su entorno para buscar
opciones de enfrentar la adversidad y
las dificultades de una manera distinta
tal vez no las oportunidades que le
hemos pedido a la vida tal vez no las
que hemos planeado tal vez no las que
esperábamos pero son eso oportunidades
en medio de la dificultad oportunidades
en medio de la adversidad
qué es la adversidad
cuáles son tus dificultades
la soledad o un matrimonio
el divorcio o un matrimonio en crisis
la adolescencia de un hijo para los
hijos que no están enfermedad drogas
alcohol abusos en tu familia
qué es la felicidad
y que es el éxito para cada uno de
nosotros
entendí que mi mejor fórmula es no
calcular mi felicidad y comprendí que el
éxito fue éxito para mí cuando entendí
que en medio de la adversidad la vida
tiene sentido
gracias
[Música]
y